[Music]
whitetail
[Music]
hahaha
wow
[Music]
uh
ah
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there i'm coming
with you
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
prey is set in the 1700s 300 years
before the first movie
and it is this creature's first time on
earth trying to find the most worthy
opponent
the predator's hunting is just for sport
he's here to compete in the game and
he's here to win
yeah no
he hasn't
[Music]
this predator he's very primal he's
going back to basics he's coming for us
he's pretty fierce
he's always looking for a fight
but when he looks for his prey he always
goes after the alpha
he's friends with earlier versions of
weapons we had seen before like the net
device
and there's the weapons that we haven't
seen
this shield that unfurls and then the
cut clamp
this is gonna be a fight to the end
to see who is the predator here
who is the prey
[Music]
something out there waiting for us
how do they know man
[Music]
[Applause]
i was excited about telling a predator
story in a different time
and it is this creature's first time to
this planet
and there's great rootability watching
someone who's made their own weapon and
seeing how are they going to use those
things to take down something with alloy
and laser advantages
this is the david and goliath story
[Music]
the very first predator set the bar for
all future franchise films
so it gives us some of that backstory
and also the indigenous survival
this version of the predator is very raw
and powerful
it really fits inside of our world
it knows how to hunt
[Music]
i know how to survive
[Music]
[Music]
you